No, of course the most famous thing about helium or at least the thing that
most people know is if you breathe in helium,
it makes your voice change makes it go squeaky.
I've never tried this.
So I decided they'd be rather fun to try this time
with Neil and Brady helping me nervous then.
Um, no, I'm not nervous yet. Well, I am nervous.
I just read on Wikipedia that somebody died off the breathing
helium, but
I hope it won't happen now to make a good fit here. If it does.
Hello.
No, don't get with helium in my voice and it quickly goes away.
And the first time I did it, I didn't breathe deeply enough.
So my voice didn't change very much,
but the second time it did change really quite
significantly.
Kara hadn't written 15 more videos to watch. In fact,
there are 117 to watch
was that it's different when you're doing it.
It just feels as if you're talking normally,
but somehow your voice comes out differently. I suppose.
It's like when you have a very bad cold or something like that,
that your voice changes as well.
I don't think that this is a good experiment for you to try yourselves.
I don't think it's dangerous if you do just once,
but if you keep on breathing helium, it can be really quite dangerous.
And in fact, I read recently about somebody who died after breathing too much,
but if you breathe helium under controlled conditions,
it's quite safe. And in fact,
it's used for deep sea divers. One of the problems,
if you're diving very deep under the sea is that you have to
breathe air that's under pressure.
Otherwise you can't open and shut your lungs under pressure.
The nitrogen in the air dissolves in your blood.
Now this doesn't matter when you're down at the bottom,
but as you come up, if you surface too quickly,
the nitrogen can come out as bubbles in your blood and
cause a very painful condition wit for some reason that Dave is
called the bends and it's been found that if you replace the
nitrogen in the devas breathing out,
or at least most of the nitrogen with helium,
then they don't suffer from bends below 150. The pressure.
On the body rises dramatically and divers must operate on a mixture of helium
and oxygen.
But of course their voices go squeaky.
So the people on the other end of the telephone,
talking to the divers need to have some sort of electronic filter
so that the divers voices are transposed and they can still understand what
they're saying.
The reason why your voice changes is probably due to a number of factors.
One of the factors is that the speed of sound is much greater in
helium than it is in air.
The reason for this is that the speed of sound is related to the
mass of the molecules in the gas that the sound is going through.
And the helium molecule is much lighter than nitrogen or oxygen,
which you find in air. Of course, if you breathe hydrogen,
it would be even faster, the speed of sound,
but you then blow yourself up.
So this is not something that anybody should try.
The other point is that inside the
human head or in fact, the head of all animals,
there are complicated resonances caused by the different spaces.
And that's why your voice changes when you have a cold,
because some of the tubes are blocked.
So I had the idea that perhaps if you
put an iPhone playing music and helium,
that the sound might change though.
There isn't much to resonate in an iPhone.
Neil and Brady were quite keen to try.
And our first experiments with a small plastic bag were a
bit of a failure. So they,
Neil got a really big plastic bag and filled it with helium.
And when you put it over the iPhone,
most surprisingly the notes didn't change,
but the sound was attenuated much more.
[Inaudible].
So it sounded much quieter.
I'm not sure why this is, but it was quite a striking effect.
And Neil put the bag on and off.
[Inaudible].
And you could hear the music getting louder when the bag was not there and going
quieter again. When he puts it back,
We did a control experiment with a bag of air and it wasn't the bag.
It definitely was the helium,
but the thing I liked best was that Neil then let go of the bag and it went up
to the ceiling and stayed there,
even though the bottom of the bag was completely open.
So once the helium is trapped in an upturn plastic bag,
it will sit there for quite a long time.
[Inaudible].
Because helium is an inert gas because it has two electrons
that are paired.
It doesn't form conventional chemical compounds in the way that
say hydrogen does or sodium,
but there's a very recent paper published just a few months
ago in this journal here where you can see it says
noble gas compounds when helium met
sodium and the people here have done a really extraordinary
experiment where they mixed sodium metal and helium gas in a
diamond anvil cell.
We have a video that explains how these work,
but in these cells you can get really high pressures.
In their case,
they went up to a pressure of nearly 3 million
atmospheres, 3 million times higher than atmospheric pressure.
And when they did this,
they found remarkably that sodium metal
forms a compound with helium, where there is helium,
which is still chemically neutral,
not helium plus or helium minus and sodium.
And in the lattice between them,
there are two electrons which are sitting there now,
normally in certain metal because the, um,
it's a metal, the electrons are,
if you'd like smear doubt delocalized through the structure.
And that's what gives it its metallic properties.
But in this sold NH two helium,
two sodium atoms, rich helium atom,
the electrons are localized and they predicted,
but they weren't able to observe the actually under these pressures,
the sodium and helium mixture should become transparent.
So it's really quite exciting.
So if your teachers tell you that helium doesn't form
compounds, they're both right and wrong. They're right,
because it doesn't form compounds under normal conditions,
but they're wrong because at 3 million atmospheres, yes, you can get some,
the reason why there's helium in the sun is partly
because the nuclear reactions that take place in the sun
are responsible for creating helium,
hydrogen atoms under these enormously high pressures and
temperature.
The hydrogen atoms can fuse together by a process called
fusion to generate helium.
Now under normal circumstances,
it's not possible to do this on earth,
but if you take a nuclear bomb,
you can use an atom bomb to trigger the fusion
of usually deuterium and tritium.
These are isotopes of hydrogen and they can be made to
fuse to create.
On this rather unimpressive barge floating in the beginning of the gun,
rested the device,
which carried the hopes for a large step forward and the weapons development
program.
The distance of the camera aircraft is 50 miles.
The frame size of the picture is 14 by 18 miles.
The film is running at normal speed.
There is also hope that you can do controlled
fusion in reactors called Taka max,
where eventually it may be possible to use the fusion of
hydrogen atoms to make helium as a way of generating
very clean electricity. However,
experiments have been going on for most of my lifetime.
And although the results are promising,
they're nowhere near being commercial production of electricity.
The most common isotope of helium is helium four with two
protons and neutrons.
There is a very rare isotope helium three,
which has two protons and one neutron and the
properties of liquid helium three are significantly
different from the properties of liquid helium four,
because at the very low temperatures of these liquids,
that quantum effects become very important. In fact, I've read,
and I don't know if it's true that liquid helium three and liquid helium
four are immiscible, they don't mix together,
which is really quite weird.
Helium three can also behave as a superfluid,
which means that it can creep upwards out of its
container. Whereas normally we've,
we put the liquid so tea into my cup, it stays there,
but imagine if it crept up the sides and went out.
So helium is a really very exciting element.
Let me start with music.